we know that parasites can make a shake
of course and siphon off our nutrients
but it's very surprising to hear that
some of them in fact there may be a
large number at least a hundred or no
nap out at this point in time manipulate
the behavior of their hosts in order to
enhance their own transmission and the
best way to understand this phenomenon I
think is with an example and one is a
cat parasite called Toxoplasma gondii I
or just Toxoplasma for short I first
came upon this learned about this this
parasitic manipulation while just you
know reading about scientific research
and I came across a study that showed
that rodents that are infected with this
parasite they can pick up the the
parasite from the ground
cats defecate this parasite so so
rodents as they're scavenging around can
pick up the parasite and it then invades
their brain and it actually tinkers with
the animals neural circuits in such a
fashion that it makes it attracted to
the scent of cat urine and when I say
attracted I mean sexually attracted the
rodents become aroused it sexually
aroused by the scent of cat urine and so
they approach and they needless to say
they're not long for this world they
soon end up in the belly of a cat and
that's the only place where this
parasite can sexually replicate they say
that's that's its little trick and it
does many other things as well for
example the same parasite goes to the
testicles and jacks up production of the
sex hormone testosterone in females by
means nobody's figured out yet it can
increase the level of the sex hormone
progesterone and in both cases these
changes make the rodent
more emboldened and caused the rodent to
sort of lower its its guard and to act
in foolish ways around cats so that's
yet another examples of other tricks it
has for you know getting back into the
belly of a cat this parasite can also
infect us one of the ways we can get it
is changing a cat's litter box and the
current thinking in medicine is that the
parasite mainly poses a threat to a
developing fetus and it can hurt harm a
developing baby's nervous system or even
called cause blindness and it's also
well known to be a threat to people who
are immunocompromised so for example
people who've received transplanted
organs or being treated with
chemotherapy and it's still assumed that
for most healthy people it poses no
threat that once the parasite gets
inside the brain that it just hunkers
down inside neurons never again to cause
any problems but there's now several
labs both in Europe and the United
States that are challenging that Dogma
and they have uncovered a lot of
evidence that for a small percentage of
people the dormant infection may indeed
have adverse consequences nobody yet has
a handle on what percentage but about
20% of all Americans are infected with
the parasite so people's guess is that
we're only talking about a small
percentage people have these adverse
responses but among other things it's a
link to mental illness so people with
schizophrenia for example they are 2 to
3 times more likely to have antigens
against the cat parasite it's also been
linked to
depression and it's been linked to
suicide
there was a actually a study done in 22
nations in Europe and the researchers
found that suicide increased in direct
proportion to the prevalence of the
parasite in each country and it's been
linked to dangerous driving
several studies in in a few different
countries have shown that people who
test positive for the parasite are more
likely to be in car accidents so it's if
one theory nobody knows for sure what
the reason for this association is but
one theory is that you know just as
rodents you know lower their guard and
they're you know do foolish behave
in a cocky way maybe people behind the
wheel of a car or you know less vigilant
or there's also research that shows that
infected people have slightly so slower
reaction times so that's perhaps another
factor that may you know influence their
driving I should emphasize these are all
correlational studies but as scientists
have learned more of what about what
this parasite does to the rodent brain
it does make them think it's it
plausible that the dormant infection is
indeed causing trouble for for some
individuals there are many amazing
examples of parasites in nature that are
manipulating behavior one of my favorite
examples is a parasitic barnacle
you know suspend any preconceived
notions you have about barnacles because
this particle is very iconoclastic it
doesn't have a shell it doesn't attach
to the sides of peers or to rocks
it's free living during one phase of its
life cycle which point it can alight on
a crab and inject a small clump of its
cells into the crab and those cells then
grow into a tangle of root like
structures and these roots wrap around
all the crabs internal organs
and eventually even sterilized the crab
and where the crab would normally grow a
brood pouch on the bottom of its belly -
you know incubate its young the
parasitic barnacle pushes out of the
crab and grows a brood pouch of its own
and from that moment forward this crab
lives and exists solely to feed the
parasite and to take care of its young
it wax you know oxygen-rich water you
know around the brood pouch to keep the
parasites offspring
you know well oxygenated and then when
the the its young are ready to be born
the crab and goes into deeper water and
bobs up and down and releases the
parasites babies and into the currents
where they then go off into the world
and only to commandeer the minds and
bodies of more crabs to me this is the
closest real-life thing to a you know a
Body Snatcher science fiction idea for
Body Snatcher because I even called them
robobot rowboat sorry robo crabs because
they are basically like an amphibious
robot controlled by this parasitic
barnacle there's many other great
examples in nature another one that I
think is very impressive is a parasitic
wasp and it will grab hold of an orb
spider and attach its egg to the abdomen
of the spider and then as this egg
hatches into a larva the larva secretes
all kinds of chemicals that effectively
instruct the spider to build it in
nursery so it at the spider abandons its
normal weaving pattern it stops making
that sort of classic circular motif and
instead creates a sort of hammock like
structure - for the for the parasitic
wasps larvae and the larvae actually
attached to the center of this of this
net and this the spider even we
weaves a sort of decorative motif around
the parasite to protect it from its own
enemies so something even as as you know
think fundamental is how a spider weaves
can be radically changed by these
parasitic wasp and there's at least a
dozen of them and they all induce
completely different kinds of webs so
that's a one example of I think a really
impressive example of a parasitic
manipulation there is a parasitic worm
that gets into killifish it's a very
common fish found in California Esther
Owens and it invades the fishes brain
and the fish as a result rise to the
surface and flip over on their sides and
basically wave their fins at predatory
birds that are you know circling
overhead which that needless to say you
know swooped down and you can eat the
the fish and the the parasitized fish
are much much more likely to be caught
by by birds at least four times more
likely to be caught what the parasitic
worm appears to do is it acts on parts
of the brain that are involved in
controlled by serotonin the
neurotransmitter serotonin and the the
infected fish seem normal and healthy in
every single way except they're much
more mellow they're like a fish on
Prozac so that's how that manipulation
works another manipulation that actually
makes me shudder when I even think about
it but it's a fungus and what happens is
ants as they're on the forest floor they
may pick up a spore of this fungus from
the ground and there is nothing docile
about this fungus because it is soon
it attaches to the ant it burrows into
the ant and it starts rapidly growing
and it as its doing this it instructs
the ant at exactly solar noon to go to
the nearest sapling to climb exactly one
foot above the ground to go to the
northwestern part of the plant lock onto
the main vein of a leaf and then this
fungus of the creeps me up like sprouts
from the ants head and it grows this
long stalk and at the tip of the stalk
is this fruiting body that then explodes
and you know rains pours down on more
ants that are you know walking along the
forest floor below